Before the birth of a hero in Enteisla,
flowers of bright red blood bloom in a land of slaughter.After the
death of the ancient king,
there is a lawless world ruled by violence and fear.I
don't like it, but there is no word as shady as Utopia.
In fact, I think the red here is really beautiful.
[Music] The
color I see now isn't scary. I
want to know the name of that color.
That's what it means to know the world.
And there's a new side to the red you were afraid of.  It's
also about knowing
your name is
[music] If that's okay,
then I'll entrust you with the knowledge to know the world.The knowledge to
feel that red, colored by fear, is beautiful.The
name of the color that [music] sees is  hey